[Music]
some say life is a rollercoaster what if
it was more like this we don't notice
the earth spinning now so what would
life be like if it's spun a little
faster would we all just get really
really dizzy how would we cope with
shorter days and less sleep how would it
affect our climate or geography if this
is modern life can we survive any faster
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the earth spun twice as fast
we don't feel the earth spinning because
along with everything else on this
planet we're spinning right along with
it at the equator the world turns at
roughly 1600 km/h completing a full
rotation in 24 hours so if you stood on
the equator you would travel about
40,000 kilometers in one day
spinning twice as fast you'd lose half
your day time would fly but you wouldn't
be having any fun
let's start with a good news weight-loss
that's right if the world spun twice as
fast you'd weigh a lot less all day
every day centrifugal force from the
Earth's rotation threatens to shake you
off the planet luckily gravity is
stronger and keeps you grounded still at
the equator you weigh about a half
kilogram less because more centrifugal
force is generated where the earth is
spinning faster which ever so slightly
decreases gravity's hold on you so
double the speed of Earth's spin and
we're all the Biggest Loser that is
because things are about to get a lot
worse
think of all your favorite TV shows and
try to come to terms with the fact that
you'll never catch the next episode
most of our satellites that are used for
communications military intelligence and
television broadcasting are synchronized
to the Earth's rotation even the
smallest increase of speed would cause
them to spin out of orbit
but who's even got time for TV these
days when days are only half as long do
you think you'd function on four hours
of sleep instead of eight how about one
or two meals a day instead of three
humans would have to design new
schedules and new calendars because
instead of 365 days in a year then it
would now be 730 hopefully they'd be
twice as many holidays as well adjusting
to a new biological clock would be tough
and not everyone would make it for
example nocturnal species would have
fewer hunting hours and may face
extinction if they couldn't adapt but
humans would need to become more
efficient too especially in terms of
energy for the average person who drives
to work they would now have to commute
twice as often doubling fuel consumption
and its effect on our climate but really
the climate would be beyond saving
for starters extreme weather would be
much more well extreme due to the
curvature of the earth wind and water
curve too as they travel across Earth's
surface this is the Coriolis effect and
it's the phenomenon that gives
hurricanes their spin so the faster the
rotation of the earth the more the winds
curve the more hurricanes spin and the
more energy they carry with them put
simply deadlier disasters but if you
like to think of yourself as a storm
chaser well then hopefully you're a
strong swimmer too with the earth
spinning at 3,200 km/h the centrifugal
force would essentially pull all the
water from the northern and southern
hemispheres towards the equator
countries like Ecuador Colombia
Venezuela Brazil Kenya Indonesia
Singapore and Australia would be
partially if not completely submerged on
top of this reduced gravity in the
equatorial region would produce more
moisture a ring of dense fog and
constant rain would
permanently cover the Earth's waistline
so the next time you have a long day be
glad it wasn't shorter our way of life
depends on it
live in the moment 24 hours a day 365
days a year
[Music]